liam's jet is airborne here albeit
silently
it's an investor video
so far no one has seen how it actually
takes off and lands
the company is surviving entirely on
promises that its jet plane will top 280
kilometers an hour with a range of 250
kilometers
there's little evidence of that so far
this is definitely
definitely what's missing
as such the claims are very very hard to
check out
certain values can't be explained with
the available data
liam turned down our request for filming
and an interview the last time we were
able to speak with its founder was last
year back then he rejected all doubts
about the concept in particular
regarding the crucial issue of battery
performance
we're in talks with several suppliers
both for the serial production and for
the development it makes us very
optimistic that by the time we make it
to the market we have reached these
ambitious goals
vertical takeoffs and landings require
enormous amounts of energy
and therefore high performance batteries
experts say the concept is essentially
possible but very ambitious
this is never gang it's happened
frequently in the past that people
focused on energy density and that leads
to having superb sales but then you
notice when it comes to storage you've
got problems actually getting it become
problem
is in a worst case scenario the
batteries could fail in flight
german company custom cells says it is
making the high performance storage
batteries but it will take time
nonetheless the ipo is speeding along
via a special purpose acquisition
company that's a listed holding
corporation whose sole purpose is to
launch a company without standard ipo
procedures so the fact that lilium
hasn't got a real product yet doesn't
matter
personally i wouldn't put any money into
that but i know plenty of people who
like risk and it suits them
and for the pastors
a lot of investors weren't convinced
though and they handed back their lilium
shares before the ipo
it'll take two to three years before
we'll see if it's jet does actually take
to the air or if it's all simply a lot
of hot air
all right we're going back to new york
now so jose was the ipo a hit or just a
lot of hot air
uh lillium ordinary shares actually had
a pretty volatile day after trading at
the nasdaq at some point they fell up to
four percent but they closed at 2.5
percent higher and let's not forget
either that
percent of quote shareholders chose to
redeem their shares as part of the
merger with lillium which is very
telling of the volatility in trading
that we saw today uh for the shares of
lillian now there seems to still be a
lot of open questions about their
business model is that worrying
investors
i think that it's a very telling that in
lilium's case and for competitors such
as jovi or archer aviation which is
expected actually to go public on friday
the way to become publicly traded
companies is through mergers with blank
check companies as you pointed out this
is a back door way to the traditional
ipo that has been losing esteem in the
last months after regulators here in the
us are toughing up those disclosure
rules all right i'm afraid we're gonna
have to leave it there that was dw
financial correspondent jose louis de
haro thank you
you